do you think your dad knows your type no
i do not think he knows my type at all
all right
need i say more
no it's scary on
perfect guy for nikki in my eyes
we expecting family person
not out there partying a lot once in a
while i'm okay with that but not every
weekend i took one look at that symptom
and said
she trying to disappoint daddy but hey
i'm not saying you should be prejudiced
against people with symptoms but you
should be prejudiced against people with
symptoms you know
i'm sorry man i'm not gonna lie to you
there's just certain accessories certain
things i'd be looking on like you're
definitely gonna choose somebody your
daddy you're gonna hate hey what what
accessories
it's not just that it's a choker is a
black
black belt and sucking dick
i'm just it's not you a girl with a
tongue piercing
uh she ain't
she can't talk [ __ ] about a church
she's gonna talk to me
if she come home and all of a sudden she
got blue hair i like avatar
does it mean you're a bad person doesn't
mean you can't have good i'm not saying
that i'm just saying i know these
patterns
but hey
ma'am be wrong today and if i'm wrong
i'll eat my words i'm still young you
know i i'm looking for some fun
adventure i want someone who like has
like goals though obviously but that's
like more of the future stuff right now
i'm like in like really my spontaneous
phase you know let me go with the flow
see if we vibe
well might as well throw these in the
fire
[Music]
hello hi nice to meet you your name is
yusuf yusuf born and raised in egypt um
traveled around for a bit ended up out
here in california i have some family
still in egypt to have family in england
so it kind of all spread out
been here for about six years i'm
studying acting for fun i'll be surfing
or skateboarding yeah exploring exactly
well have you ever find a chance like
you just want to go and get pack and
take off without saying anything or any
to anyone hey yo shout out to tommy
tommy immigrated here
right put on his best 90s males porn
star outfit but kept the accent on thick
and i respect that iris i like hearing
access like that even though sometimes a
bit of a struggle i respect it you got
the johnny cage though yeah you just
want to pack up and go and leave
like you're going to pack up and go and
leave my daughter
yo shut up all right love that [ __ ] yeah
listen get it if i ever find the chance
or like like
like eventually when you're thinking
like okay i'm gonna go to like china and
just practical this is what they could
tell anybody you know
take off and disappear
see the right answer i should say no i
would never just leave without telling
anyone
but i mean you have come to the math
equation and done in english literature
we don't want to know about shakespeare
we have asked you a simple question
but i mean
backpacking in china sounds kind of fun
okay now so uh you have you ever been in
any relationship
uh
wilson wilson yes how are you wilson i'm
doing good
tell me about
yourself myself i'm born and raised in
singapore my parents are from indonesia
currently i'm a junior at the university
of southern california studying computer
science i'm very good how do you have
your relationship with your family you
know i'm really close to my mom actually
just last week i flew back to singapore
like just after finals ended just to
spend some time with my mom and then
came back here because starting
internship like soon so what about like
after school i mean the dream is like as
a computer science major obviously like
get a nice comfortable tech job right
like something like apple or facebook
something like easy and then but if it's
like real aspirations like one day like
do a startup he went man this guy
getting no [ __ ] though yeah i mean
he's like
i mean he's [ __ ] corny that's
what they think
and the dad's thinking
good for my daughter
that's the worst part is that all these
[ __ ] like in in high school
all these people were last yeah we're
all last no oh look at you y'all grown
what you doing you do science oh
i'm good yeah
i'm an actor and producer i've just been
kind of building my career family wise i
have 10 siblings my dad was kind of a
wild guy in his early 20s he was a
director in hollywood so he just
had a lot of kids i'm close with about
two or three of them is it real you're
acting right now
hey hey got jokes
tommy got jokes shout out to him all
right what's the order you think it
would be
time to say singapore then i'm going to
say
5 4
3 1 2. i think this is going to save the
exact same except the black guy and the
last dude are going to switch
can i have uh
you step over here please yeah and can
you take that
for now
let's go to you anthony right yeah if
you are in the relationship with nikki
how
romance are you thinking yo dad that
ain't on your business dad yo
he's trying to find the right man for
his daughter yeah i'm a [ __ ]
i'ma [ __ ] your daughter i'ma [ __ ] your
daughter i'm gonna make her feel good
and she's gonna come three times
but i'll bring chocolate first
it's like you that is in your business
like how romantic would it be
sometimes i don't want to see like
boring oh yeah no no 100 no i i feel
like me like at least my past
relationship i'm very romantic um how
are you approaching her do you believe
in the first kiss
no i believe first date is the day you
get to know them um if it's going to
work out if you guys have that
connection with each other and then from
that point on you guys talk about how
you feel and what should be your next
step what's the proper next step to take
so if you're in first date with nikki
are you gonna lead in with first kiss no
i'm gonna wait for a dad to choose me
i'm not gonna lie my mom would have been
like i don't believe
i don't believe i don't believe i
thought
that's what you bought you should have
said this guys why that's yeah
are you
looking at any kind of commitment or
you're just like okay this is your life
i mean like like other boys a lot of
boys just like going out and having fun
all of my friends out there they all
have girlfriends and stuff like that i
just want to have one too i'm sorry to
get to the point my life where i am
starting to think about like long-term
commitment i've been in a few
relationships and they've lasted like a
year or two i'm looking for something i
can see going long distance or you know
looking for a stronger commitment you
know no one's going to look up that's
like man no i'm just trying to look for
a one-night stand i'm trying to clap
some asian booty get that vietcong you
feel me nobody gonna say that i saw her
she got a fat ass
you did good bro i put it there nobody's
good no we're gonna say that
not not personal but when you're talking
about you know last
few relationships
how
i'm in college right now i'm moving
around a lot and i didn't realize that i
was kind of causing some of the
conflicts there was
alright
make some moves right here and um can
you choose switch please
can you choose please
yeah i'm kind of happy with this short
kings
short kings out here okay so let me tell
you this right now
use of going to the top
asian and short dude going towards the
bottom i would say asian dude's gonna
end up like black dude's gonna be second
third or second black dude gonna be sir
third second white dude gonna come in
four that's my guess actually you know
what
you said first
black guy second yeah
damn we got ben i think this whole thing
is inverting yep i think it's inverting
i'm nikki nice to meet you guys nice to
meet you forget ideal first date if we
were to leave here right now where would
you guys take me it was 11 o'clock i
think sushi dance hotel opens at eleven
all right i'm kind of hungry right now
some ramen
like thrifting you know there's like
stores open painting something like that
uh i i just happened i want to see it
again
we leave right now you hop on back my
motorcycle venice beach or something
let's go youtube
you said first yeah
that's for sure yeah you said about to
get in them pains walk up here
so you guys outdoorsy types or like home
bodies
outdoors
like if it's like a group of friends
they're like i'll plan a trip and like
in super like this weekend going joshua
tree like super done for that the same
time other weekends just want to stay
back right so what are your like hobbies
and interests i enjoyed playing guitar
sometimes write music it would be
anything adrenaline related doing such
things as like if there's a swell we'll
go out and surf the big waves or
swimming in the ocean and off the boat
like whatever there's not like a ton of
stuff to do in indiana so i found a lot
of fun stuff to go do with my friends so
like a cool yeah it's kind of far
just a little but you know so we're
always finding like going hiking in the
woods or like going to a concert
somewhere uh i like to go jet skiing or
anything kind of beach related i love
the beach i'm trying to get my pilot's
license
make that hobby just go flying
i think it's my thing user going first
um
asian dude gonna go
second
black dude going fourth
uh short mexican dude staying last white
boy one third
use it first
black asian anthony and whatever is ben
okay
thank you first
aj and yusuf
do you guys know your astrology signs
capricorn do you know
i know that i'm a scorpio moon
capricorn's like my uh like earth sign i
don't even know what that means to be
honest
um so i actually tell you no i don't
like challenging science yeah i'm a
philosophy major and i have a whole
report i'm not a huge fan of uh
[Laughter]
ladies if i can give you guys any piece
of advice and i mean this like the
bottom of my heart okay shut the [ __ ] up
about the astrology right sorry
go ahead my bad
i don't think ladies understand how much
dudes get so [ __ ] annoyed when you
guys bring that [ __ ] up i was just
looking at her some regular girl living
her life and then she brings this [ __ ]
up and i'm just like ugh and i'm just
saying this it's in your best interest
i'm not gonna lie if i'm talking to a
girl she started getting talking about
astrology she yapping about it it's a
big ass turn off it's like finding out
that [ __ ] don't clean a room
i just started looking like i don't
think i could do this it's exactly like
ladies imagine if you go on a date with
a dude and everything goes well and he's
like so
uh
do you know your basic bread pill
terminology
your [ __ ] gonna dry up so quick same
thing
i was like tall and deep like y'all
right red pill you're you're an
astrologer how do you feel about andrew
tape just no just just
stop bringing that [ __ ] up jesus [ __ ]
christ
it's crazy how much it just sours my
mood but i know i'm not alone because
most dudes right now guys put a one in
the chat right now if you guys hear
astrology and immediately your dick just
shrinks
ugh
ladies just don't do it even if you like
it keep it to yourself yeah
i like a lot of nerdy [ __ ] you know what
i
mean
i like video games i like anime what i
don't do on a first date and be like
[ __ ] how you feel about naruto no
don't do that
and you already know some nerd ass woman
oh yeah i'm sorry like this you already
know some nerd ass woman in the comment
section but well actually i will i
wouldn't date you
okay
started from the bottom now here you
guys are wondering why the asian guy is
at the bottom and i'll tell you guys why
this is the truth
and because he's a bad date is because
one she kind of gets the vibe that her
dad would approve
and two
she want to live her best life and he
seemed like a bit of a square yeah all
right so you're talking about the future
of buildings talking about spontaneous
and duh so who ends up first the [ __ ]
surfer do like i said and the white dude
coming in second
indiana the guy with indiana's far and
then
indiana still still
feel like i'm upside down
i mean like ways of what personality
what else
i put yusuf first because i liked how
like fun and spontaneous he sounded and
stuff like that i'm still young you have
fun this is what young people do i'm not
even gonna get mad at her she wanna go
do her stuff that's fine
the other day she's about 22-21 who
cares so i would be like yo you missed
out on a man who we listen most people
at that age are not thinking about that
[ __ ] so she got to go out and do her
dumb stuff and then
get with a dude like yusuf who's going
to leave her behind to go to china she
should she go learn her lessons the hard
way like we all had to do all right i'm
happy she she stuck with what she was
saying she did so i'm happy for she's
consistent as long as it's just there's
no astrology
don't bring this don't do it don't do it
don't do it don't do it don't do it we
don't want that no stop
[ __ ] that [ __ ] don't [ __ ] do it and
on top of that you don't even know about
astrology don't do it if you if you
reach for the stars
you are going to
end up in space
yes
don't do it